père le voile se lève enfin sur l'invité
mystère nuit tard gueulard couche-tard
pinard pétards léotard c'est pas que les
gens encore peu sûrs avec la vue mis ce
faire
je crains pourtant l'émission nombreux
chinois si tu penses interpellé c'est
pas le congolais c'est quand je dis hou
là là t'as vu c'est ton droit chinois
jeudi dans là à mon avis s'ils étaient
pas en ombres chinoises ce sera tard
les gens se disent qu'ils étaient le
robert mitchum français ah oui oui oui
dans les buts on ne vit pas dans le bon
sens mais c'est chez pai est tellement
mitchum et
alors évidemment par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres acteurs j'ai l'impression que
ça aux gens ouais ils ont pas vu les
autres alors regardons les siens j'ai vu
un film là de toi qui l'a passé à
télévision le 1er octobre qui s'appelle
les sirènes de minuit
on est venu c'est un très très très très
grand film pour moi j'ai un fils
mouvement mais qui est grand parce qu'il
est presque et du rose dedans parce que
du rouge devant parce que elle parce que
le moteur le mobile c'est du racine pour
moi le mobile
c'est l'amour et mécanique implacable
une phase qui commence à wil chl aussi
c'est quand j rachid propos talent mais
c'est comme une tragédie très bien
composé
et le drame du cinéma français c'est
qu'on s'attend quand on voit une
tragédie acheteurs je veux dire sans
lier je m'en souviens de l'école mais là
le lyrisme biais d'une façon une version
moderne dans l'image mais attention plus
tout le monde voit tous les jours dans
sa vie non c'est matt bondir comme on
dit pour résumer shebab selon travailler
quelqu'un way qui pour moi est un des
meilleurs mais pour - philippe lefebvre
on devrais je parle a donné une leçon et
ces temps derniers rôles d'alcoolo
pareil c'est à dire à l'eau bon ben j'ai
trouvé je trouvais le theule maintenant
j'ai trouvé un point de chute qui m'a
expliqué comment il fallait faire pour
faire semblant
par exemple pour faire une scène
débrouille toi papa non le problème
n'est pas là problème il est drôle c'est
comme si le gars chez des collègues
pensaient que le boucher est un tueur un
peu d'ail ou de vous jouer mais vous
n'avez pas voir c'est comme si orient
justement parlez vous avez un prénom qui
va au chantier à plein il a été aidé
dans mon cas parce qu'ils jouent bien je
fais bien les alcoologues à manger un
seul problème c'est que je les sais je
suis le meilleur pour ce problème
ces jeunes jouent mieux que les autres
alors qu'un lac numéros verts ont saisi
les seuils de fer l'alcool aux isérois
je travaillais pas je travaillais c'est
donc d'années de pratique
m